six-year-old Florence Widdecombe loves
to send and receive Christmas cards but
chanced across one made in China which
delivered the opposite of Christmas
cheer my wife bought some parts from
Tesco and she was at home cooking
and as she was cooking Florence here was
opening those cards and whiten them for
her school friends in the primary school
class and then you opened one Florence
and she started laughing and she said
mummy this card's already been written
first the family had no idea what
Florence had stumbled across very weird
I started chuckling I thought maybe it
was a prank or something this is the
card Florence discovered with a message
inside which read we are foreign
prisoners in Shanghai Ching poo prison
China forced to work against our will
please help us and notify human rights
organization the message urged the
finder to contact someone called Peter
Humphrey without saying why
Florence's father tracked down Peter
who's now living back in the UK it
transpired Peter had been jailed in
chinku prison accused of illegally
obtaining information following his
investigation into a Chinese
businesswoman what's the message that
they want you to deliver the message
that they want me to deliver is a
message to the world to tell the world
that prisoners in China are being
mistreated and being subjected to forced
prison labor for companies ultimately
that don't know what is happening with
their product in the supply chain and
you obviously spent a considerable
amount of time in jinpu jail what was it
like the prison regime in Chengdu prison
is pretty bleak Tesco says it's charity
cards will raise three hundred thousand
pounds this year but insists it had no
idea how they were packaged in a
statement Tesco
said we were shocked by these
allegations and immediately halted
production at the factory where these
cards are produced and launched an
investigation the human rights issues
raised by the christmas-card are a lot
to take in for a six-year-old girl but
this is one Christmas message Florence
Widdecombe won't forget Lisa Holland Sky
News